you
[Music]
the next session which is titled
technologies for India I am very excited
to now present the track owner and the
moderator I would it's my great pleasure
to introduce dr. Haman Pandey him and
did his BTech from IIT Bombay and then
went on to do a em film and a masters
and a PhD degree from Rutgers University
in the u.s. after that he spent time at
Siemens and PRD DC you know as part of
his industrial labs experience and he's
been for a long time now with persistent
and most recently he is currently
holding title of executive director at
ACM India and he says he has about three
decades three decades of experience
after his education so without further
ado I will hand it over to him and who
will introduce a track and our esteemed
our lineup of speakers for the strike
hey man thank you thank you thank you
very much Satish so welcome to the to
the final session of this academic
research summit jointly organized by us
three entities so we have seen really
excellent session starting with Raghu's
session about the technology which is in
place
coming in place already deployed then
shiron talked about the challenges of
post certain challenges and things like
that and followed by that we had really
interesting sessions where there talks
or panel discussion and things like that
from people in academia are talking
about the things that they are working
on with what that work could be applied
to and people from industry talking
about again here are the problems and
what if that kind of thing so throwing
challenges at the audience audience over
here which is academic end people from
Microsoft Research and so on so
consistent with that but with a little
twist we said that let's organize
session with team which is India scale
challenges and you know when you say
India scale what kind of scale that is
so as a VM mentioned yesterday morning
our Charter it I cesium India is to
advanced computing as a science and
profession and within that what we are
also trying to do is foster
collaboration between industry and
academia so in order to do that what we
said that in addition to this
technologies for India for that scale
which may or may not involve that just
be very honest upfront machine learning
AI and I leave it to the speakers so
bring that aspect in of startups or
private companies with ambition to solve
India level problems through technology
and also seeking collaboration with
academia so that is the focus that we
have for this this session and we got
some really good speakers here from a
diverse background so somebody not
needing to go to college to do wonderful
things to doing PhD at I seen in the 70s
okay so this kind of not panel but the
set of speakers that we have and they
will talk about interesting problems
interesting challenges that they're
working on in private industry and again
as a theme talk about the opportunities
of working with academia to
of the hard problems okay so to start
with I would well invite syrup Sara
punch money who is like me he is a
graduate of IIT Bombay also stayed in
the same hostel briefly so the bond is
even stronger so he again did his PhD
after IIT BTech he did his PhD from UCSD
in cryptography so he's an authority in
cryptography and he will bring out that
mention in the in the talk but again
I'll leave it to him it's really new
stuff that these people at I spirit are
working on so he's full time at high
spirit which is technology think-tank
which encourages and supports products
from India for India at world class so
he represents that it's a nonprofit
organization he has worked in Microsoft
Research so he found Microsoft Research
India so he did find some colleagues
over here and then he joined Bell Labs I
don't know what comment that will elicit
from from Chandu and then he said that I
want to do things at India scale and
overall support the aspiring industry
products so without further ado I'll
hand it over to him please welcome sir
observer of punch1
so as the Hemant men mentioned I'm a
crypto person by background but this
talk is not gonna be able crypto
actually expecting crypto plus a I
applied for India scale problems and
social good you're not going to get that
much of a masala but
you know this this is this is a fairly
important problem in a very relevant
domain where AI comes up a lot
healthcare and the problem itself is is
it's not immediately clear whether ml
and AI will be immediately relevant in
solving the problem the will be will be
relevant in solving the immediate
problems but they will show up in the
long run for sure
it's a very fundamental problem in
healthcare that we are grappling with
countries across the world and and
hopefully I'll be able to inspire some
of you ml nai experts to come with us
join us in trying to solve this problem
Narendra Modi and his team up in Delhi
launched this grand program called -
Bharat three months back and this has
been the talk in the news in an Indian
media and all the people like Bill Gates
tweeting about it fairly ambitious this
is very ambitious program and already
had a significant reach and the main
point here is with programs like these
and a lot of four straight versions of -
Bharat running now the reach of health
insurance in India is rapidly increasing
you know today it stands at something of
the order of twenty percent twenty to
twenty five percent people are covered
by health insurance today but with these
kind of grant programs coming in the
reach is going to increase dramatically
and only one hundred days this program
has touched close tuning it's about I
think the number of people touched is
about six hundred six hundred thousand
and the number of claims processed was
of the order of five a half a million
the problem with with irishman rather
than a lot of the state-sponsored
insurance schemes is that we are ending
up aping a lot of the things that have
been done in the West in terms of
implementing does he did insurance
programs and and insurance driven care
has some serious limitations which
basically come down to two things one is
this whole point that you know most of
the the whole idea of insurance driven
care is centered around you know
centered around treating sickness and
there's there's a disproportionate
amount of emphasis given to sickness as
a port as opposed to overall health and
well-being of the individual
insurance companies reward sorry
reimburse doctors for the volume of
treatments that they provide to base and
not for the overall value that the
treatment spring brings to the patient
in the long run patients themselves
consumers themselves are not told by
insurers to take care of their health
you know they're taking care of your
health is not a mandate of insurance
companies and that's something that you
know that's something that insurance the
insurance world doesn't even touch upon
or very rarely touches upon the other
problem which we we refer to as
procedure inflation stems from the
inherent asymmetry that exists between
between the insurer world and the and
the health care providers world insurers
are I find it difficult to completely
ascertain that you know medical
treatments that are given for certain
conditions were were really required or
not right so just a stock statistic in
this context is what goes on in the u.s.
in the u.s. about a third of the
surgeries that are performed are
unnecessary in nature is essentially and
that that means that non surgical
interventions for those conditions were
not even considered before before the
surgeries were performed
people are getting root root root
implants even though there's there's
nothing seriously wrong with the teeth
and many various stories and this has
you know a lot of long-term I mean this
of course damages health in the long run
and I already have a question this must
be really interesting yes good yes I'm
coming to that the slide doesn't have it
yet but the oh in DIA what is the %
India percent I don't think we have such
granular data for India because they're
all this data sits inside insurance
companies on database and this is it's
not a very open system in India yet it's
probably more in the u.s. than in other
parts of the world because the US
healthcare system is definitely much
more criticized than others but but we
don't have draw exact data for India
yeah so so the the core issue is that
there are no incentives that this whole
insurance care
model there is there is no a limit of
incentives either on the consumer end or
on the provider end to think or act in
terms of long-term health and well-being
of the entire population so doctors are
not incentivized to give good care which
could you know which could which which
could guarantee long term health for the
patient and patients and patients and
consumers in general not is not
incentivized to make good health
decisions even before they fall sick and
this is you know it's a well-recognized
problem in in the health health care
space and there are some there's lots of
TED talks on this economists articles on
this it's we believe is particularly
pertinent in India today a naturally
source of people did I didn't yeah and
people have tried to solve this problem
in the West and the the problem they've
run into is that is essentially legacy I
mean the insurance the idea of insurance
is so entrenched in a lot of developed
economies that changing those systems
becoming very difficult which is why I
feel it's quite pertinent in India
because in India penetration of
insurance is still pretty low it's about
of the order of 20 percent or so as I
said 20 percent people insured by health
insurance today and growing rapidly you
know with the iPhone Bharath with a lot
of these state-sponsored schemes and
private insurance now turning around
profits it's actually growing rapidly so
it's it's this is the right time and we
should intervene and try to bring about
a change and so what what we are
proposing here is something essentially
simple but going to be extremely hard to
implement so our idea is you know let's
let's broaden the scope of scope and the
role of insurers let's let's transition
let's think of transitioning insurance
insurance companies to take the shape of
what we call care intermediaries well
they're not just doing playing the role
of care financing but they're also doing
incentive management they're providing
incentives are the both both the
consumer and the provider end in and
towards making you know
towards making healthcare decisions
which benefit the population in the long
run and we we propose a new kind of
mechanism so we essentially say that
this should this can happen through a
new kind of care policies health care
policies which we refer to as a game of
fire policies which would have tools for
incentivization built into them and so
the tools which would incentivize both
consumers as well as providers to act in
a manner which benefits overall health
of of the consumers and and you know
it's a game of fire policies we you know
we will bring in techniques from micro
economics and behavioral economics to
accomplish this objective in order to so
essentially the idea to is to influence
healthcare decision-making for consumers
and providers so that there is long term
globally optimal decision making and
yeah just just one small body I mean so
this this whole idea of bringing
incentive schemes in two insurance
policies has been attempted in small
pockets in the world and even in the
u.s. this is beginning but the efforts
are very sparse and far apart so this
slide essentially gives you a quick
example of what a game if I have policy
might look like so so the idea is you
know it can be used can we use auctions
which is which is a which is a highly
popular tool from
microeconomics and it's used actively on
the internet today near every time
you're making a google search query
you're making a Facebook post there's
someone behind the scenes running an
auction and delivering those ads to you
which are shown in the shown the way
they are on the internet so online ID
options or you know have been quite
successful for achieving you know
effective commerce on the Internet and
so the thinking is you know can be
exploit and auctioning mechanism to make
provider to consumer mapping more
effective and can use that as an
incentivization tool can can
used that can be used the idea of
auctions to help providers
reduce reduce their costs and - yeah and
to keep the cost low Thant and in an in
process to address procedure this is a
problem of procedure inflation in
practice you know you know this could
end up in looking like something like
this as shown these four pictures you
could imagine a user going to care
intermediary specifying a specific care
requirement like I want to get a
cataract surgery done and the care
intermediary would at this point run an
auction where it could invite bids
across various hospitals and doctors in
the vicinity of that individual to come
with proposals for you know what how
much it would cost to - - to undertake
the surgery and and then their intended
intermediate intermediary would rank the
the providers out just the way our
listings are created on the internet and
in doing this ranking it made it may it
will of course use the price the the
bidding the the bid submitted by the
providers as one of the key inputs and
other than the bids itself there could
be some quality scoring that it may
apply and qualities coding is important
you know you don't want price to be the
only determinant for for for these
provider listings and and post that you
know the the consumer would select the
select the provider of his choice and
then the price of the treatment would be
decided essentially dynamically and so
it's it's not something that it would
remain across different treatment
requirements the next time the same
consumer goes to the intermedia they
could be different price that comes up
for the same treatment and because of
this whole you know auctioning process
you know there's one is the pricing of
the procedure becomes dynamic and the
other thing is providers are
incentivized to keep the prices low
because otherwise they their chances of
being selected by the consumer reduces
so so that's it's auctions at one
possible tool that one could use for
gamifying the mapping between consumers
and providers in healthcare
decision-making and there could be a
bunch of other tools and this is you
know there's there's there's a weave
we've done a survey on the potential
tools one could use from the economics
literature - - as in and and say and
using that survey figured out some of
the potential tools that are available
we are not economists ourself and we are
actually talking to some economists to
get deeper into this you know what are
what how big that toolbox can can be but
the key challenge here you know so in
terms of trying to solve this problem at
a 10-year scale level and coming our
solution was really work is this
question that I posed here so so we have
a lot of these techniques available from
the economics literature but figuring
out what works and what doesn't
requires really experimentation and this
is something that economists grapple
with you know it's they don't have it's
it's hard to come hard for them to come
to really good answers to this kind of a
question without running running
large-scale experiments and so so the
main proposal that we have is that you
know we should be trying to address this
problem by building an experimentation
framework which allow the
experimentation with game fire policies
and you know so a framework which allows
creation of a large number of
potentially millions of of game fire
policies could be created using this
framework and and you know running
running running real experiments around
these policies on real people and then
assessing the impact on health outcomes
so it's of course it's not going to be
it's these are going to be long-term
studies that you run using this
framework but the main point is you
should you should there should be a
language available to care
intermediaries to be able to to define
to be here to be able to define policies
you know which have incentive tools
built into them and you know and using
this language they should be able to run
experiments at at at different
granularities
yeah and you know and you know from from
a data perspective I think one of the
challenges one of
interesting problems which will come up
in the in the long run is once we have
this kind of framework running and
policy policy experiments happening
these experiences throw up a lot of data
and care intermediaries you know may
want to may have sir may have some
privacy concern with this with respect
to this data of course data interchange
is important it's important that what
what one learns from one experiment gets
shared with with other people in the
ecosystem a care intermediate should be
learning from each other's experiments
and that can you know that that requires
a secure data data exchange kind of
mechanism and that's that's one place
that I think that you know the role
where data will become key but at this
point I think the you know the the real
important problem for us to solve is to
create this kind of an experimentation
ring of course there are you know there
are regulatory issues here you know and
that's something that there we are doing
in parallel so this is of course you
need to go coming we need to go convince
the people at irda the idea is the
regulator for insurance in India - - do
you even think about broadening the
scope of insurers and to talk about
incentivization as a as a key part of
insurance policy that's something that
that's the conversation that we are
having parallel but at the same time you
know it's important to start building
this kind of a technology framework and
this is this is one value that we as
technologists can add to - in this whole
space of healthcare incentives so say
it's a it's a rich area of collaboration
between put a rich array of potential
collaboration between computer
scientists and economists and we invite
so this is still early age thinking for
us you know it's not that we've gone too
deep into this problem where while we
talk to computer scientists we are also
engaged in engaging with a can of
economists in parallel and trying to
figure out you know what are what are
some of these approaches and how you
know what wow you know it figuring out
how what goes into the toolbox and what
would be most relevant for the for the
healthcare domain but in parallel I
think it's interesting to start thinking
about this framework and trying trying
to design it and so that's where I think
you know the computer scientists like
you can come join us and participate
that's it thank you questions this is
not the example that you use the one
example so I forgot to mention there's a
there's actually paper we've written on
this and if you want I can we can share
that paper with you and we have more
examples in that paper and you know
there's of course I mean it's preventive
is also is also something that you've
considered yeah so so essentially
there's a lot of work on health care
regimen so there's you know so both
preventive as well as curative you know
so far it's actually much more work on
the curative side there are things like
diabetes or TB there's a rich literature
on that but similar stuff on preventive
as well and so what what forum for
someone who's prone to having that
likely to have diabetes what are the
what is the kind of lifestyle he or she
should be living so that you can prevent
the onset of that and so essentially
it's the idea is you know can we can we
take some of the elements of those you
know the the so-so regimen adherence
tools is what I what I classify I call
them
can we bring in some element of regimen
adherence tools into game of fire
policies that you must work closely with
some of the insurance from pleaser
yes we've spoken to be spoken to a bunch
of them work closely is yes which
insurance company do you really feel
like is more adaptable to this kind of
technology I said so actually the one of
the surprising things we found is that
insurance companies in India are already
beginning to look at incentivization on
the consumer end so there are there are
two companies that we found which you
already have in their existing insurance
policies some terms around if you take
care of your health
I'm going to give you a there's no India
so it's a bit lies one of them I just
don't remember the other one I know that
Billa
allative auditable as one of them and
the other one I I don't remember but
yeah a message for the people that they
should stay away from Bigler should stay
away from stay away from bill insurance
company because the premium is likely to
increase the premium is likely yes so
actually one thing that yeah that's a
very good point so incentivization of
course that it's gonna cost money you
know I mean running this framework of in
itself is going to be an expensive
affair so we have to think through I
haven't spoken about the financing of
this thing and but the the hope is that
you know the financing can be jointly
managed by industry and the state you
know say in any last scale solution like
this will require some stated them in to
intervention and it cannot be just
insurance companies by themselves should
not be the only ones sponsoring or
incentive scheme the other way this it's
not going to work at last year so we
need some state involvement on that
front but the cost of health care is
both by insurance companies often so
what you're saying is that overall cost
does come down then there is an
incentive for the insurance company as
an intermediary right yeah exactly so
that's very intimidating not okay in the
case of annex right because there is so
much you know data and so on one can
hypothesize you know policy one policy
too and we can you know figure out what
will happen to our p.m. there is a
machinery that exists and understand you
know what you can do experiment right if
you want to collaborate the computer
scientists right what are you expecting
from them I mean are you expecting them
to build simulators are you expecting
them to somehow with you and so I think
it's level one as I said I don't know
why this keeps disappearing but the
level one is is it it's okay I'll just
talk the first level is coming up with
machine readable language for defining
policies and that is something that
clearly requires some computer science X
so it may not require ml expertise at
this point because I don't think that's
that's not really an ml problem
obviously but it requires and requires
people like you to people with the
formal methods and languages drag it
back down to come participate because
and this is something that we are doing
in the insurance spare space in general
so even before we think about
incentivization and you know holistic
health and everything came processing
today is is a largely manual manually
driven process you know you know not so
much in the West but definitely in India
and to bring in more automation into
that process we need to be able to cast
current day insurance policies into
machine readable format that's one of
the essential problems that we need to
solve before we can even think about
automation and that is I won't say it's
a hard Communist problem but it's an
important Commission's problem and it is
hard to the external some of these
things they have a lot of legalese and
it's not even possible to capture all of
this insurance terminology in in you
know in a in a touring company during
complete computer language or I don't
think that's something that is even
feasible but it's it's something that
you know we have to make an attempt at
and I think the eventual solutions will
have mixed flavors of you know some some
machine readability and some some non
readability and that's that is an
essential component where I think you
know people who have any interest in in
in in solving this problem should come
and talk to us about because that's that
clearly requires engineers and
scientists to scientist expertise what
you said but then machine learning would
definitely come in to with children
you'll be recommending that you know
these are the doctors we are
recommending and then when you'll be
ranking them because you'll need some
ranking system to provide the order that
way this is number one this is number
two this is number three
so definitely four recommendations as
well as ranking
have to have machine learning solutions
here feature I is the data for the
doctors coming from the hospitals may be
or may be consumers some pass data or
labels labels basically then you have to
apply machine learning on top of that
yeah that's a good point so I think at
this point our exploration of you know
this toolbox that I spoke about has been
mostly within the space of the economics
literature and it's not clear if that
has all the solutions to these problems
and in fact a lot of the regimen
adherence work that we've studied
actually has come out or come out from
the medical medicine literature not from
the economics literature and you know
there might be some ideas in the ml
literature which could indicate solution
but we've not so actually I mean we
don't have the solution frankly and this
is something that this is the main
message to you we don't have the
solution for this VR we want to create a
framework which would allow solutions to
bubble up quickly and and the solutions
will involve new kinds of techniques
which are not covered in the literature
currently may consider you yeah mainly
speaking I don't think solution and
technical solution or email solution
would be a major problem I think major
problem here could be getting the
training data you know getting the data
from hospitals or maybe you know clients
or you can say patients because they
will be giving recommendations they will
be giving rating you'll say if I have
done some if I have got done some
surgery for my eyesight or anything I
will be I'll have to give some rating to
my doctor right so you'll need that data
to train your model I think that would
be the biggest challenge and that would
be your first preparatory stage to work
on that thing first machine learning can
definitely give the solution yeah that's
a good point
I don't I think we're running out of
time so let's I'll leave that you you
might want there's a lot of talk this
has also been involved in some of these
data effort ritai spirit and he'll he'll
he'll touch upon that yeah so I think
with that comment I will thank several
thank you very much